one of the biggest sponsors in Esports
is collapsing as we speak FTX a
cryptocurrency exchange had previously
sponsored team solo mid to the tune of
210 million dollars but that seven-year
agreement has barely made it to year two
now that FTX is in the middle of a
serious implosion and the timing isn't
exactly great either I mean Esports
hasn't been bulletproof this year and
crypto as a whole is somewhat on the
downswing right now so today we're
taking a look at this FTX situation and
asking what does it have in store for
Esports and where might it go from here
foreign
hey guys before we get into the video I
know it's that time of year when things
are getting colder you might feel cozy
want to curl up on the couch with some
entertainment we're happy to help so if
you enjoy yourself today why not click
the like button and if you haven't
already subscribed to the channel you
can do that and ring the notification
Bell if you're feeling really generous
okay back to the video so the first
order of business is just to talk about
what has actually happened with FTX and
then later I'll get to the Esports
implications so if you've been following
this situation you don't need to recap
you can skip to the time code below I'll
see you there okay so cryptocurrency
that's the thing we're talking about
right so what is it a cryptocurrency is
a speculative financial asset that is
typically produced through a process
called mining where a computer solves a
complex mathematical equation and then
slaps the answer to that equation along
with the token owner's name on this long
digital Ledger called the blockchain
okay yeah this is a very simple
explanation but I don't have time to go
super in depth on proof of stake as
opposed to proof of work and all that so
definitely if you want to learn more
about that you can check out a more
in-depth video but honestly if you want
to understand what happened that's going
to be enough so FTX before its recent
troubles was one of the biggest crypto
exchanges on the planet essentially you
could use one of these crypto exchanges
to turn digital currencies into other
currencies either hard currency like US
dollars or perhaps another digital
currency like a cryptocurrency The
Exchange in turn usually charges fees
for the swaps much like if you convert
currency at a money change or a destroy
it mall or something in a lot of these
crypto exchanges you have to actually
deposit your crypto into an account in
order to get it changed so what that
means is that there are a lot of people
in this specific circumstance whose
money may go down with the ship which is
not good more on that in a bit FTX as I
said was a huge player in the space but
they were comparatively pretty new they
were founded in 2019 by two MIT
graduates Gary Wang and Sam thankman
freed the latter serving as the
company's CEO weirdly over the past
couple years bankerman freed who I will
now just refer to as SPF which is as
common moniker had developed this kind
of bizarre following and Persona they
call him the JP Morgan
of crypto right
yeah but FTS was committed to
popularizing both crypto and of course
itself so it splashed a lot of money on
marketing we're talking professional
sports stars like Tom Brady and Stephen
Curry what do you think you in you know
what I'm in let's call everyone I'm not
an expert and I don't need to be with
FTX I have everything I need to buy sell
and trade crypto safely they bought the
naming rights to the Miami Heats venue
they got their logo on Major League
Baseball
umpire uniforms and BMW's F1 team they
sponsored the Home Run Derby X chess
tournaments the Golden State Warriors
and the Washington Capitals they bought
a games developer whose CEO was a former
Magic the Gathering world champion and
Hearthstone lead designer and yeah they
sponsored some Esports stuff including
tournaments but they also Inked some
huge Esports deals the deal to become a
naming partner with Team Solomid was a
record-breaking seven-year 210 million
dollar partnership and they also became
sponsors of the LCS another seven year
deal that even Riot said was a record
for their Esports leagues now in Esports
the FDX sponsorships were primarily
these awareness kind of passive
marketing sponsorships but in their
other materials it's pretty clear that
one of ftx's major aims was to make
people scared about missing out on
crypto I'm pregnant
I'm so happy blockfolio by FTX okay
who's going in back here infinity pool
yeah
we struck Royal this place is a gold
mine what
it's FTX it's a safe and easy way to get
into crypto
yeah I don't think so and I'm never
wrong about this stuff never
sorry I couldn't resist and uh maybe
I'll get Larry David to help me with my
peckham's next major but anyways a lot
of people bought into the hype of both
FTX and crypto but FTX is now seemingly
headed for bankruptcy to cut a very long
story short in September a Bloomberg
report pointed out that FTX was very
cozy with another firm Alameda research
perhaps a little too cozy given that
they were also co-founded by SBF
Bloomberg's reporting argued that If
This Were a regulated financial sector
this relationship would likely have been
shut down by Regulators then an article
in early November by coindesk noted that
a massive portion of alameda's assets
took the form of ftx's proprietary
cryptocurrency ftt how does this work
Mac the money keeps moving in a circle
but we don't have any money all we have
is this
how does this work I don't know I
thought I thought you what suddenly
binance the biggest crypto exchange
announced that they would be selling all
of their ftt and because ftt wasn't
exactly a hot commodity dumping that
much of the token onto the market tanked
the price and as it turns out fear Cuts
both ways the announcement of the sale
caused people to panic people were
trying to pull their money out and with
so many people trying to pull money out
it caused what is called a liquidity
crisis which is essentially like FDX has
some liquid money but if everybody wants
their stuff back at once well they're
gonna have to sell some stuff that takes
time and the stuff they're selling well
that could also have changed in value so
then binance looked at and decided
against a purchase of FTX and then the
United States Securities and Exchange
Commission and commodity Futures Trading
commission opened investigations into
what was happening over at fds and a
bunch of money allegedly went missing
too now most of ftx's Affiliated
companies as well as Alameda research
have filed for bankruptcy and it
certainly appears as if there will be
some people who have trouble getting
their money back again this is a very
fast overview of the situation these
things are changing almost hourly at
this point and there are a lot of people
perhaps a million people who could be
listed as creditors with FTX and while
this is a blow to cryptocurrencies
generally it probably isn't the end of
them but I am willing to bet that
governments are going to be taking a
much closer look at cryptocurrency and
specifically the regulation part okay
but what does this mean for Esports
specifically well the LCS and TSM just
lost a huge sponsor obviously in the
case of TSM they've since issued a
statement that their books look good
even without the FTX deal we have no way
of knowing if that's true but let's be
real 30 million dollars a year is a lot
I'm sure they had plan hands for that
money and even if they're fine without
it that probably means at least in the
short term they've got to cut back on
some stuff that they were planning to do
and honestly even if TSM is completely
fine this damage to crypto generally
could still hurt Esports now I'm not
saying that Esports should never take a
gambling or crypto sponsorship
necessarily just that we should be
honest about what it means for the
industry when they do because TSM isn't
the only team with a crypto sponsorship
and while some of these deals are pretty
big we should be careful about these
teams getting addicted to them Furia was
also signed to FTX liquid signed a deal
with coinbase another exchange dignitas
sold naming rights to Quantum pay a
digital bank that processes crypto
exchanges team Vitality launched a
support to earn blockchain based app
yesterday like literally yesterday at
the time that this video is published G2
Esports signed an agreement with bondley
only to have to sue them when they fail
to follow through on their agreement to
produce nfts team secret was sponsored
by uniswap a decentralized crypto
exchange fnatic partnered with
crypto.com in a five-year 15 million
dollar plus deal and in Rainbow Six
Siege crypto sponsors went a bit wild
too I could literally keep going but I
think you get the point by now a lot of
the biggest players in Esports are
taking these crypto deals and well I
think we have to be honest about how
risky this is because if crypto
evaporates the money does too that could
mean some pretty bad things for Esports
generally frankly and that's just
considering the possibility of a general
crypto downturn and not you know another
FTX type situation in an industry that's
frankly plagued by poor oversight I'm
not responsible for balancing the books
of Esports orgs thank God but if any of
them are relying on this money they are
playing with fire and all of Esports
could get burned right now in the wake
of this whole FTX thing I think even the
most dedicated Defenders of
cryptocurrency have to accept the fact
that failure is a possibility in this
whole Venture and how could they not
right now the value of these things is
determined almost entirely by the
willingness of new customers to buy in
and maybe that's why so many of these
crypto companies seemingly use fear to
convince people to get in fast now
before it's too late fortune favors the
brave
and fans yeah maybe even you haven't
been oblivious to that these these
cryptocurrency deals haven't exactly
been the most popular and fans are quick
to voice their opinion about just about
anything
as you should you deserve it in fnatic's
case they even got so scared of fan
backlash that they stopped calling their
nfts nfts in their posts and lastly
let's not forget that it's been a rough
year for Esports more generally if the
ambition some might say greed of certain
stakeholders pushes them further into
bed with crypto well
I worry for the future because crypto's
success is anything but guaranteed and
building your house on that Foundation
is like crypto itself right now A gamble
because I want Esports to keep growing
and I don't want its growth to be
contingent on something as flighty and
unregulated as cryptocurrency
thanks for watching if you if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring the notification Bell
for Unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit us up on our
Twitter Instagram Facebook and tick tock